today on the matt walsh show our good
friend christy gnome wrote an op-ed
explaining what she thinks conservatism
means and what conservatives should
stand for her ideas in this regard are
pretty standard for republicans they're
also wrong i'll explain why in five
headlines including the texas abortion
bill effectively banning most abortions
in the state went into effect this
morning it's a wonderful moment and uh
and significant progress in the right
direction but leftists as you can
imagine are quite upset that fewer
babies will be dying we'll talk about
that plus joe biden gives another
address to to the nation to defend his
catastrophic failures in afghanistan
every time he tries to defend himself he
only looks worse and the la unified
school district
sent out its covet guidelines for the
school year and they're as deranged as
you might expect in fact they might be a
little bit more deranged than you even
expect we'll talk about all that and
much more today on the matte wall show
well i can tell you one thing for sure i
really missed my helix mattress last
night as i was sleeping on a bale of hay
with mice nibbling at my toes
uh helix
mattress that is uh that's that's that's
something that just makes sleeping so
much easier helix sleep they have a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you i mean why would you buy a mattress
made for someone else that's okay you go
to a store these are mattresses made not
with you specifically in mind
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling down if you sleep hot
uh whatever the case may be and even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers just go to helixsleep.com walsh
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free
and if you don't like it then there's no
risk you can send it back but you will
have it trust me you're not gonna ever
want to sleep in anything ever again
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep dot com
slash wall street's helix sleep dot
slash welsh for up to 200 off and two
free pillows
there are you know two questions that
nearly every conservative i've ever
spoken to has and the first is what
exactly he should do about the fact that
he lives in a collapsing civilization
that is run on every level by people who
hate his guts and stand opposed to
everything he believes in and who wish
that he was dead
second question every conservative has
is what exactly is a conservative anyway
and it's always seemed apparent to me
now more than ever that we're not going
to be able to come up with a
satisfactory answer to the first
question until we've answered the second
because any conservative response to our
cultural decline any plan of action and
any battle strat strategy
must begin with figuring out who's on
your side
what your side is
and crucially what exactly you're
fighting for
because following the culture war today
feels a little bit like you're watching
a fight scene in a movie you know a bad
modern action movie the camera is
shaking and moving around quickly the
lighting and the outfits tend to blend
everything together and it's impossible
to tell who is fighting who and who the
good guys are and you leave the film
with a headache and little idea about
what you just watched or why
disorienting is the word and it
certainly applies to our culture as well
so my dear friend governor christinom
just wrote a piece for the washington
times which i i think puts this problem
in sharp relief which is why it's worth
talking about and she she represents one
form of conservatism a common form
uh though in a sort of obscure and
misshapen form the wrong form in my view
and the form that has presided over
the cultural and civilizational decline
that i just mentioned
um it's the form which has achieved
nothing has no victories to its name at
all
has suffered one defeat after another
for decades on end and she's taken upon
herself to become a champion for this
form of conservatism
and her her op-ed in the times is i
think
almost laughably absurd on a number of
levels but it's worth responding to in
some detail so she obviously wrote this
partially to defend herself from recent
criticisms from people like myself but
also to promote her vision her tired
failed vision for the future of
conservatism so let's check it out she
writes quote you can't be a
constitutional conservative only when it
suits you we are now seeing a battle in
the republican party between the
populist wing and the traditional
limited government conservatism
some so-called conservatives want to
regulate businesses to prevent them from
requiring a covet-19 vaccine as a
condition of employment still my beliefs
do not allow me to waive the
constitution because i disagree with the
private business it is human nature to
want to wield power and a crisis adds to
that impulse as an emergency unfolds
many will insist that somebody should do
something and governments eager to pass
laws and hire people with weapons to
enforce them
step in
uh it's up to pro-liberty liberty
conservatives to stand on principle and
to stand up to government mandates
now she's correct that somebody do
something
that attitude is dangerous and i've
talked about that many times there are
lots of people who when a crisis hits
they
just cling on to the nearest government
official and they and they say well save
us do something dear god just do
something anything this is a bad
instinct and she's right to criticize it
so that part is good
but we already detect some warning signs
that things are about to go off the
rails here intellectually speaking
because she says
that it's human nature to want to wield
power and maybe she's right about that
but then again if you're the governor of
a state or if you're a legislator or you
know if you've been
elected to the government
wielding power is exactly what you
should be doing now don't wield power
for power sake don't wield it for the
wrong reasons or in the wrong way or to
the wrong ends
but you should be wielding power that's
why you're there
that's why you've been put in that
position the problem with republicans is
that it's not that they're discerning
and restrained and thoughtful in the way
that they wield power
it's that they don't want to wield it at
all
so we'll keep reading to see where this
goes she says to be clear i don't think
businesses should require a cova-19
vaccine as a condition of employment i
also believe that government is too big
and mandates are not a conservative tool
enforcing the behavior of its citizens
uh since when did the republican party
become the party of big government and
social engineering using government
power to force behavior
once we as a people open the door to
increase government power to put
mandates on businesses expect a
pandora's box of liberal mandates to hit
in the future that touch on faith the
right to keep and bear arms and the
expanding list of genders the left has
invented william f buckley once referred
to the growth of government as creeping
socialism we're seeing a version today
with both republicans and democrats
calling on the government to mandate
behavior they find acceptable even if i
agree with a new mandate the mandate
limits freedom and sets a precedent for
even more mandates taxes spending and
expansion of government into the daily
lives of average americans who just want
to be left alone i'm reminded of a
famous reagan quote the most terrifying
words in the english language are i'm
from the government and i'm here to help
conservatives see that liberals are
trying to use this crisis to expand the
size and scope of government at every
level on everything from mandates to
spending the left wants more government
conservatives must stand on principle
and oppose big government in all its
forms now
all of these are pretty standard
republican talking points
nothing shocking or egregious here
and we're used to hearing republicans
say stuff like this we've heard this for
years and years and years
kind of your basic stump speech
but that's precisely the problem
right
more specifically i think i see three
problems here so let's go through them
number one she says that if republicans
use power to mandate behavior then we
can expect a pandora's box of liberal
mandates that deal with uh
gun rights and and gender and all that
stuff to happen in the future
but this is not a prediction of what
will happen in the future this is a
description of what is happening right
now liberals are already doing
all of those things
they're doing them even though the
republican party has hardly wielded any
power at all even when it owned both
houses of congress and the presidency
didn't do anything
the past a few mild tax cuts that's all
they did
now we're constantly warned that if
republicans start playing hardball and
actually you know making laws and trying
to put their agenda into action then
democrats might start doing the same as
if democrats are waiting on permission
from republicans to advance their own
cause and yet democrats are already
doing that and have been doing it
while republicans sit on their hands and
say oh you know we can't cross that line
because if we do democrats will do the
thing they're currently doing right now
and have always been doing
it doesn't really make any sense
second she says that um
conservatives must oppose big government
in all its forms
now it sounds almost like heresy for me
as a conservative to
disagree with that or criticize that
notion
but
i think we should stop and think about
this
what does this even mean
you know we're so used to hearing
republicans rail against big government
that we don't stop to ask what they mean
anymore but we should so so what what do
they mean
no republican administration in living
memory has made any serious effort to
actually shrink the size of government
none of them have
i mean trump certainly didn't
george bush obviously didn't i mean
you'd have to go back many decades to
find a republican
who arguably put a plan like that into
action or at least tried
most of them
have actively
expanded it
so republicans pay lip service to this
idea but we never know exactly what they
mean because none of them try to put it
into action none of them
which is a common theme here
and maybe part of the problem and part
of the reason why they don't abide by
the small government motto
is that the motto itself is vague and
sort of you know
arbitrary is the problem with government
that it is simply too big is there just
too much of it to go around is it as
simple as that
or is the problem that our government
points its power in the wrong direction
and does the wrong things and has the
wrong priorities i mean ask yourself
this if democrats get their way and
manage to push through a law
that provides federal civil rights
protections on the basis of gender
identity
uh the the the equal rights um or the
equality
law
is is is what they're trying to push
through and it's in the senate right now
meaning that all bathrooms and sports
teams and female facilities across the
country must be open to men
will this be an example of a government
that is merely too big
or will it be an example of a government
that no matter how big or small it is is
fundamentally corrupt
and run by radical left-wing
i mean the answer could be both of
course
but the big government thing distracts
from the real problem and it turns what
could be a pointed criticism and a
useful criticism into something vague
and ill-defined
the effect of all this generalized sort
of big government talk talk from people
who again
have never done a single thing
ever to actually shrink the size of
government
the effect is that now if you advocate
for the government to do anything
if you push for any law or any policy of
any kind you're accused of advancing big
government
there are even some so-called
conservatives and we'll talk more about
this in a minute
who will accuse you of big government
if you
say that we should
restrict or ban abortion
so that's expanding government we can't
do that
third point finally gnome says that
mandates are not a conservative tool and
that we must put we we must not put
mandates on businesses
on twitter when sharing this article she
actually said
that we should not be in the business of
forcing behavior of any kind on to
people
we should not be in the business of
forcing behavior of any kind on to
people
wait what
we shouldn't force any behavior
no mandates at all
is that why we oppose mask mandates
simply because they are a mandate that's
not my problem with them i take issue
with the substance of the mask mandate
and many other mandates
not with the simple fact that it is a
mandate
so this is all quite incoherent i think
the fact is that any law of any kind
good law or bad law must necessarily
force behavior onto people
now i know that i'll be told that well
the good laws are the ones that prohibit
behavior rather than mandating behavior
now i'm not sure why prohibiting is
automatically better or more valid than
mandating
we're expected to sort of just agree
with that underlying assumption but i'm
not sure that i do
and anyway the bigger issue is that
every prohibition
every single one
is also a mandate
for example if you're prohibited from
driving over 75 on the highway then
you're mandated to drive 75 or lower if
you're prohibited from neglecting your
children
then you're mandated to care for them if
you're prohibited from murder you're
mandated to not murder
if you're prohibited from uh you know
driving drunk then you're mandated to
drive sober
if as conservatives we want to prohibit
abortion which we do then we want to
mandate
that mothers give birth to their
children unless the child dies
tragically through a miscarriage
obviously
these are not semantics i mean this is a
fundamental and essential point about
the nature of law and its purpose
so many establishment republican types
advocate for in the way that they speak
about these issues it's like they're
advocating for this kind of
anarcho-libertarianism
well we can't force any behavior we
shouldn't we shouldn't mandate anything
even though they're not really
anarchists or libertarians
but that's the language that they use
it's just lazy
and it confuses conservatives
and it adds to this environment where
conservatives don't even know what what
this what we are or what we stand for
the argument that we shouldn't force any
behavior of any kind is silly if not
completely insane and it's obvious that
nobody who says such a thing really
believes it but they make the argument
anyway because it allows them to
sidestep the discussion that they're
afraid to have
yes of course government should both
prohibit and mandate certain behavior
what kind of behavior
and why
well
this is a simple question
it's also the central question in this
debate
and it's time that we start actually
thinking and talking about it
and speaking of mandating and
prohibiting behavior we'll have more to
talk about with that when we discuss the
texas abortion law that just went into
effect which will be next in our five
headlines
now a quick word from our very good
friends over at rockauto.com
you know i've been saying all summer why
do you want to waste time at a at a auto
parts store when it's nice out and you
can go outside well actually the summer
has has proved at least in in nashville
to be rather oppressive and so you'd
rather just stay inside your house now
as we get into fall though that's when
it really makes a difference and who
wants to you know you could be hiking in
the woods or something rather than going
to an auto parts store especially
because you're just wasting your time
wandering around the auto parts store
with this very limited selection because
i only got so much space inside the
store you could much more easily just go
to rockauto.com pick up your phone go on
your computer go to rockauto.com you're
going to find the lowest prices possible
and you're also going to find the best
selection anywhere you're not going to
find a better selection in any auto
parts store guarantee they're a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique and
very easy to navigate and you quickly
find everything you're looking for so go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and wright walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
all right well uh we're on the road this
week uh as you can see and as you have
also seen
uh we've been staying in some in some
very interesting places i don't know how
this room comes across on camera
this room is actually a lot better than
the one i'm staying in
so this is my producer sean this is hit
his room
i'm staying in uh in in a basically like
a dungeon
and uh it's it's like the kind of
roadside motel looking things it looks
like the kind of place where serial
killers murder people
uh maybe they just come by like three
times a week and murder people kind of
on a schedule
just like cockroaches there's a bat
flying around in the bathroom all that
kind of thing ominous
scratches on the door
no ac
in in the room at all
the thing is i'm so naive that i we
walked in here last night and i'm and i
was saying well i hope they have room
service because i'm really hungry
they kind of laughed when i asked about
it
and then i was told that uh if you if
you want to get food you got to go down
to the uh to the gas station it's the
only place around here that has any food
so i went to the gas station
and uh and had a delicious dinner uh you
know and you you you know you compare
that like when if if ben shapiro's on
the road he's broadcasting from like a
five-star review resort where they have
a concierge that comes and fluffs the
pillows
meanwhile i'm sleeping on like a
mattress on the floor covered in bed
bugs
it's great it is it is it is really
wonderful
um
okay so some good news some more good
news to start from the new york post it
says a strict new measure that
essentially bans abortion in texas went
into effect at midnight despite protests
and lawsuits against the harsh mandate
uh this is the new york post language
anyway the harsh mandate the law
prohibits women from getting an abortion
after a fetal heartbeat can be detected
and gives citizens the right to take
legal action against doctors or anyone
else who helps a woman terminate a
pregnancy most women who get an abortion
in the lone star state are at least six
weeks pregnant and will now be unable to
receive the procedure according to
planned parenthood and whole women's
health the texas bill differs from other
similar heartbeat laws nationwide
because it bars authorities from
enforcing the ban
and allows anyone else to take legal
action
under the measure anyone who
successfully sues a doctor or accomplice
would be entitled to at least ten
thousand dollars which critics claim
will flood the courts with opportunistic
legal cases
and yes people who are opportunistically
trying to stop babies from being killed
very very opportunistic of them the
wide-ranging provision allows suits
against patients nurses counselors or
even someone who drove
a patient to an appointment uh so that's
the law that went into effect there was
a there was a mad dash by the
pro-abortion pro-death pro-baby-killing
side to stop it and they weren't able to
and now the left is
absolutely panicking over this as you
can imagine the aclu
which is supposed to be the civil
liberties institute they're supposed to
stand for liberty and you would think
the most
fundamental and basic liberty is is is
that to
to live the right to life
because if you don't have the right to
life the ability to live then then all
of your other rights would seem to be
sort of null and void
but they're very pro baby killing and so
they sent out a whole series of tweets
um
they said the supreme court has not
responded to our emergency request to
block texas's radical new six-week
abortion ban the law now takes effect
access to almost all abortion has just
been cut off for millions of people the
impact will be immediate and devastating
uh and that that's these are the words
i've seen the left using in response to
this bill
which is expected
devastating tragic
unjust
infuriating
nancy pelosi called the law a
catastrophe a catastrophe catastrophic
because because
fewer babies will be killed that's what
they're upset about
it's catastrophic
that now we're going to allow
more children to live
corey bush
sent out this tweet she says i'm
thinking about the black brown
low-income queer and young folks in
texas the folks this abortion healthcare
bill uh healthcare ban will
disproportionately harm
wealthy white folks will have the means
to access abortion our communities won't
now i'm not sure how uh
an abortion ban will disproportionately
affect uh quote unquote queer folks i
don't know how that how that works
exactly
but this is the only
tune that corey bush knows and so she
just hums it every single time no matter
what the issue is
it's always going to be well this
disproportionately impacts
these uh these people
now does it in disproportionately impact
the black community
in a sense yeah but what is the
disproportionate impact
because there is a because
a disproportionate number of black
children are aborted that's
true and so now the disproportionate
impact is that more black people will be
allowed to live
okay there will be more black people in
texas now than there would be without
this bill this bill
will will have the direct and immediate
effect
of ensuring among other things along
with saving so many other babies
but since she brings up these protected
classes
it will also have the immediate effect
of ensuring that more black people will
live in texas
and corey bush as a black woman is is
opposed to that
whichever if you're opposed to it then
come out and say it
just come out and say it i i
i
i
want these black children who are going
to live now i think they should be dead
i think that um they should not be
allowed to continue existing
come out and say it if that's your
opinion because that is your opinion
um now is is this law
in texas is it in keeping with roe v
wade
supreme court's going to weigh in on
that
and i don't have a whole lot of
confidence in what their decision is
going to be
i have confidence in maybe
two of the uh of the justices on the
supreme court thomas and alito when it
comes to to this issue on the rest i
don't i don't know
but does it violate roe v wade
my answer is who cares
i i don't care if it does
rho is imaginary
okay
they located the right to abortion
in invisible ink in the constitution
or they may as well have
the roe v wade decision may as well have
said well a uh
a fairy came in to our chambers
and sprinkled pixie dust on the
constitution
and invisible words
suddenly were made apparent that said
you have a right to an abortion they
that may as well have been the decision
because it is that absurd
has no basis in reality whatsoever
again they they they located
the right to abortion constitutionally
within
the constitutional right to privacy
which is not a constitutional right
so there's nothing in the constitution
that says right to privacy
and that's what they based the right to
abortion in
and even that's not in there so this is
the right to abortion is is two degrees
removed from the constitution
it's grounded in constitutional language
that does not exist itself
so it's a horrible decision that even if
you're an honest pro-abortion person
which is a category of people that i'm
not sure actually exists
just as the right to abortion doesn't
exist but if you were then
you sh even you should say yeah i think
that abortion is good or whatever i'm in
favor of it but uh there's no right to
it in the constitution
a couple other points here
as we see the left panicking over this
bill in texas now that more children
will be allowed to live
um
i've got to make this point again for
the millionth time but it's so important
because what we're hearing over and over
again
and what you'll continue to hear is that
this bill is an attack it's an assault
on reproductive rights
i have to continue to emphasize that
it's not an assault on reproductive
rights
because because
this has nothing to do with reproduction
abortion has absolutely nothing to do
with reproduction
reproduction is a separate issue
do i think that women have reproductive
rights
of course
i will say this right now with without
any hesitation at all
no woman
anywhere on earth
should be forced to reproduce absolutely
not
i mean the the thought is is
atrocious it's horrifying
the idea that any woman would be forced
to reproduce
the good news is that that's not
happening in america
anywhere
okay
now with abortion
what happens is you are killing
a human being
who has already been produced
reproduction birth is not reproduction
when a woman gives birth to a child this
is basic biology that i know is lost on
a lot of people these days especially on
the left basic biology
birth
is not the reproductive act
okay reproduction is conception
that is when a separate and distinct
entity with its own dna
comes into existence that is
reproduction this this being this entity
has been produced in that moment
now you can call that uh this being
anything
the correct thing would be human
baby works also person all those work
but you can even use an euphemism like
fetus fetus just means offspring in
latin so sure it's offspring
whatever label you want to put whatever
whatever whatever word you want to use
that being exists and has been produced
in that moment
nobody should be forced to conceive but
once conception has happened the being
now exists
anything you do after that is after
reproduction it is too late to prevent
the reproduction of that person
if you are
preventing a an already produced
human
from being born
you are not preventing that human being
from being reproduced
any more than if i shoot you in the head
before you walk out your front door in
the morning i haven't stopped you from
being reproduced i have just stopped you
from
changing locations i have stopped you
from emerging from one location into
another location
i've maybe stopped you from becoming
visible to people outside
but i can't shoot you in the head and
say hey man this is my reproductive
rights
uh one other point
real again really basic
if the government
does not have the authority or the right
to pass a law like this
if the state government in texas doesn't
have the authority or the right to pass
a law saying that you can't kill you
cannot kill human beings that have
heartbeats
then government should not exist
there's no argument that i can think of
or that i've ever heard
that would explain you know
why we should have a government at all
and yet not one that will protect the
most innocent and vulnerable among us
like that is the most if if government
has any role
then that would be their most
fundamental and basic
and primary role
to protect the most innocent and
vulnerable
people could not protect themselves
people who uh
if if the government does not step in
and pass laws protecting them then then
there's then that's it then they'll be
killed
if the government
is not in the business of doing that
then it shouldn't be in the business of
doing anything
if it doesn't have authority and power
in in that realm then i don't see how or
why i should have authority or power in
any realm
so god bless texas and uh thank god for
all the babies that will now be granted
the
i won't even say will be granted the
gift of of life because they're already
living before the abortion happens as we
discussed
will be granted the gift of continuing
life
the ability to fully you know
explore their own potential as human
beings
uh
until a judge comes in and blocks the
bill anyway okay so joe biden again
addressed the nation
yesterday about i was about to say last
night about afghanistan but he never
speaks at night you know
which is a little bit suspicious as a
not really suspicious at all in fact as
a man struggling with dementia very
publicly and very obviously
he's not he can't speak past about six
o'clock
in the evening so he was supposed to
speak i think around three or four he
was late again he's always late for a
guy who likes to check his watch he sure
is late quite a lot
but here he is starting with this
talking about
how
this evacuation was actually an enormous
success let's watch
last night in kabul
the united states ended
20 years of war in afghanistan
the longest war in american history
we completed one of the biggest airlifts
in history
with more than 120 000 people evacuated
to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
the only united states
had the capacity and the will and
ability to do it and we did it today
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
for weeks
they risked their lives to get american
citizens
afghans who helped us
citizens of our allies and partners and
others on board planes and out of the
country
and they did it facing a crush of
enormous crowds seeking to leave the
country
the guy can't even speak it it's always
hard to listen to him
but joe biden he did it in that speech
um
that that part right there that 60
second segment was him bragging about
how it was a huge success because they
were able to get all these people out
now he doesn't
you know he he doesn't want to dwell on
the fact that yeah we got 100 000
afghans out afghan citizens there are
still americans being left behind
he talks about
the bravery and skill of the people on
the ground our troops on the ground who
were doing all of this and yeah
they they had immense bravery
um they're not the problem you don't
need to defend their bravery and skill
we we all acknowledge that
the issue is you
okay and the brass the pentagon
and military leaders
okay
the the guys who before all this were
happening they were talking about how
you know white privilege
is is the greatest threat that the globe
faces and so on
that's who work
that's what we're criticizing not the
people on the ground
but he
he shifts constantly between saying
that this was a great success it was an
enormous success
uh this is like dunkirk this was a this
was just a
an incredible feat of human engineering
and
technical brilliance and so on
and also
this is all my predecessor's fault
so he's
he he blames trump and then also brags
that it's a great success
so his point is his argument is
this great enormous huge success
is all the fault of donald trump
it doesn't get any more coherent than
that because next he starts talking
about
um or addressing
the criticism from lots of people myself
included every i think everyone has had
this criticism which is why didn't you
evacuate the americans first
and here he tries to explain
why i take responsibility for the
decision
now some say
we should have started mass evacuation
sooner
and couldn't this have been done have
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully disagree
imagine
if we've begun evacuations in june or
july
bringing in thousands of american troops
and evacuating more than 120 000 people
in the middle of a civil war
there still would have been a rush to
the airport
a breakdown in confidence and control of
the government
and it still would have been very
difficult and dangerous mission
the bottom line is
there is no evacuation evacuation
from the end of a war
that you can run without the kinds of
complexities
challenges threats we faced none
yeah man there's no easy way to do this
evacuation
it's a hard thing to do these
evacuations he says
uh
that's really his answer this is a
written speech okay this is not him off
the cuff we know that that goes off the
rails very very easily this is but this
is a written speech he's still reading
from the teleprompter
and he was late showing up there they
were working on the speech at the last
minute trying to get it exactly right
coming up with some kind of response to
the criticism that hey you could have
gotten the americans out first
and his answer to that is
hey man i disagree i mean
if we did it that way
it still could have gone bad
that was his answer
it yeah it this went terribly even
though it was a great success
um
but if we had done it the way that seems
like it would have made a lot more sense
it still could have
not been great
that's really his answer which is to say
he has no answer at all
that should put to rest if you had any
you know if somehow you had any notion
in your head
maybe there are some things you don't
know about and there's like a reason why
they had to do it this way
a good reason
well he would have told us what the good
reason is and there wasn't one as is
clear now
okay a couple other things also a couple
other things from the biden
administration uh i thought this was
kind of interesting this is a warning
from the state department it says
afghanistan travel advisory level 4 do
not travel to afghanistan due to civil
unrest armed conflict crime terrorism
kidnapping
and covet 19. travel to all areas of
afghanistan is unsafe
terry you can get your head cut off
um you could be enslaved sold into sex
slavery tortured
thrown into prison
uh for the rest of your life
down in a cave somewhere and also you
could get covered
so this is like if it was a travel
advisory level four do not launch
yourself directly into the sun due to a
certain fiery death and a gigantic
flaming ball of lethal gas
also the uv rays will make your skin
wrinkly
travel to all areas of the sun is unsafe
um there's also this from
the uh
from the cdc okay now i i don't want to
seem like i'm
just
getting a
ticky tack here with my criticisms of
the cdc but
this is a tweet from the cdc
talking to people who have lost power
because of the of the hurricane says
have you lost power
when in doubt throw it out throw away
perishable refrigerated foods like meat
seafood milk and eggs if the power is
out for more than four hours
learn more food safety tips for power
outages and then there's a link to it
now i just read that because it just
shows how
the cdc they these idiots really cannot
do anything right
they really can't
even something basic like
food safety
tips which i guess i could see why the
cdc would chime in on that
there are illnesses you can get from
unsafe food okay
so this is sort of within their purview
fine they can't even get that right
throw away your food after four hours
all of your food in your refrigerator
no please i beg you if you lost power
you're probably
not listening to this right now if you
did but
do not throw away all the food in your
refrigerator
just keep the door shut
and the food will last for for
many many more hours than that
even days potentially if you keep the
door shut okay your food your
refrigerator is a cooler
even without power it keeps the the cool
air in
you can even do other things like if you
still have ice in your in your freezer
then you or if you got some ice before
the power went out you could put bags of
ice in the refrigerator
functions as a cooler keeps things cold
so please do not do that
the cdc would have people after a couple
hours yeah i've got to throw away all
the food
and now i'm going to starve i guess
because i just threw all my food away
for no reason
these absolute morons
speaking of morons i got to mention this
briefly as well
the la
uh county unified school district
has put their covet guidelines into
place now that the school year started
and this is i want to read to you some
of an email from an la school district
union representative to teachers
this is an email that somebody sent to
me
from an la
teachers union rep explaining you know
the guidelines and what they're supposed
to do so let me read some of this okay
it says
um this is why it is so critical to
continue safety practices like properly
wearing a mask please make sure that the
mask covers your mouth and nose i've
observed a number of our colleagues
ignoring this and walking around with
gator masks or face masks that barely
cover their mouths let alone their nose
even if you're vaccinated breakthrough
cases and the delta variant are still a
risk while vaccinated individuals
reportedly experience very mild symptoms
they may still act as a carrier for the
infection wearing masks improperly puts
colleagues and students at risk further
it indicates to students that they don't
have to wear the mask properly either
now this is not the really crazy part
but it's still crazy
i mean the claim that
a vaccinated person
who's wearing a mask but just has their
nose sticking out
is a threat to other people
so if you're vaccinated and you're
wearing a mask and only your nose is uh
is is out
and there's another person who's wearing
a mask also and let's say they're also
vaccinated or even if they're not
the risk is what that you just through
breathing normally through your nostrils
that the nostril air from the vaccinated
person
is going to infect
someone else
who's wearing a mask
is there any evidence that that has
happened
even once
any evidence that that has ever happened
i'd like to know
the email goes on further since the mass
mandate is a state and district
directive you may be subject to
displayed action if you are not wearing
the mask appropriately and since mask
wearing is part of the negotiated side
letter you will get no relief from the
union
so this is the one thing i mean this
teachers unions they'll defend
teachers to the hilt on anything you
could have rapist teachers teachers who
are sexually abusing their students and
the teachers union will come to their
defense but if you're if you're not
wearing your mask appropriately that's
where they're not going to defend you
hey you're on your own sucker sorry this
is when it really uh gets crazy speaking
of students please insist that students
always wear masks and step outside if
they need to drink water be sure to wash
hands often for 20 seconds and sanitize
your hands your hands when you can't
wash finally maintain at much as much
distance from students and colleagues as
possible and
avoid unnecessary gatherings like eating
lunch together also keep your hvac
system running all day in order to
filter the air and leave doors and
windows open when possible
even if there's construction noise
outside
that's
uh first of all so i guess i guess we're
not worried about climate change anymore
you need to cr crank the hvac system
with all the doors and windows open
so you're really you're really taxing
that system churning a lot of co2 in
there so we're not worried about that
anymore
you got doors open with construction
noise and jackhammers outside who cares
if you're if the kids can even hear what
you're saying
and if if a kid
needs to just
take a drink of water
they got to go outside of the classroom
to do it
because a child who is already at a very
low risk to contract or spread covid
if they just take their mask down for 10
seconds to take a swig of water
in those 10 seconds while they're
swinging water they could infect the
people around them
again is there any evidence that that
has ever happened
or could even or could
reasonably theoretically happen any
evidence of that
no none at all
and they're still going with the washer
hands all the time which yeah i mean
washing your hands in a norm washing
hands is just good practice in general
but we're still you know wash your hands
constantly sanitize all the surface even
though we know that kovid is is airborne
it is not really spread
primarily
uh through through surface contact
it's very rarely spread that way as far
as we know
but that doesn't matter we're just going
to pretend that's not the case
all of the have you noticed the coveted
safety guidelines
they haven't changed in 18 months
no matter what else we learn about the
virus
the safety guidelines stay exactly the
same they do not respond to the science
at all
but these are the pro signs people of
course all right
i'll go now to reading the youtube
comments
um
this uh says it's a shame matt show
doesn't last longer because he's a
perfect white noise machine for my week
old baby mabel
she goes right to sleep when matt starts
talking newest member of spg and
probably the sweetest well
she's not paying attention to my show
so she's banned from the show
so are you
well congratulations on the birth of
your child
uh
c warvold says man every time i watch a
video of yours i realize how wonderful
and gifted an orator you are every video
so far without fail leads me to feeling
like i've experienced an hour's worth of
content before you even get to your five
headlines thank you for sharing your
talents with the with the wire world
is that a compliment or was that a
passive aggressive insult
so that the show you're saying every
show after 10 minutes feels like it's
been an hour
the show drags on is what you're trying
to tell me
you sir banned from the show how dare
you
um yo mama's boo says i don't give a
damn if you're in a crappy hotel room
i'd much rather be able to see my sweet
daddy walsh rather than just be able to
hear him
don't ever leave us again
oh you thought the hotel room yesterday
was crappy you ain't seen nothing yet
we're just getting worse and worse
um
and by like friday i will be in a cave
i'll be in a cave in afghanistan doing
the show
uh the other one says
day five of asking for matt's thoughts
on pineapple on pizza well i really
don't i know this is one of those
controversies i don't have strong
feelings on it
part of this just goes to my my
gluttonous instincts i'll like eat
anything
so i'm not crazy about the pineapple on
the pizza but it's pizza so you put
pizza in front of me i'll eat it i don't
really care what's on it it's pizza as
far as i'm concerned
um
and finally paul says the irony of
people first syntax is that it employs
relative clause construction the
function of which is to establish a
defining statement by declaring a
general category term
superordinate which is then restricted
by excluding everything that falls
outside of the subordinate predicate
phrase in short it's exclusive and
restrictive
now
yeah i was going to say that myself
thank you paul that's exactly my point
whatever the hell you just said you know
once a month uh hosts of the daily wire
come together for a backstage for some
light-hearted debate and sometimes not
so light-hearted debate as you saw at
the last debate but the last step
backstage but it was certainly uh really
interesting and
a lot of fun for everybody involved and
i'm extremely extremely excited to tell
you that our backstage in october is
going to be staged a little bit
differently instead of just
tuning in from your home you'll be able
to see us live and on stage at the ryman
auditorium right here in nashville
doing what we do best making sense so
join myself jeremy boring ben shapiro
michael knowles andrew clavin and
candace owns for a backstage like never
before we have a very special offer for
members if you're a daily wire member
you have a special 12-hour window to buy
your tickets ahead of general admission
starting tomorrow thursday september 2nd
at 10 a.m central check your email for a
special code that you can use to
pre-order your tickets if you're not
then you're just going to have to wait
until tickets go on sale this friday
september 3rd so mark your calendar and
make sure you don't miss out now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so we've talked rather extensively on
the show about the supposed eviction
crisis that we've been promised for some
time and it's because of this supposed
crisis that democrats
of course according to democrats anyway
the cdc must be allowed to continue
forbidding landlords from evicting
tenants who don't pay their rent never
mind that the cdc doesn't have that
authority never mind that the policy
deeply infringes on the basic human
rights of property owners
we must they say allow these people to
remain in homes and apartments they
aren't paying for uh and we must allow
this indefinitely
no matter what
now i confess that i haven't been
persuaded by these arguments
up until now
because all of that changed
uh with a report just published in the
hill which i which i read yesterday
here's the headline
nearly half of lgbt renters behind on
rent fear eviction in next two months
and this is credited to research by the
way it says nearly half of lgbt renters
behind on rent theory eviction the next
two months colon research
well who could dispute that if research
has declared it
the research has spoken
but in any case i for one will
completely abandon my views on this
issue now that i know that some gay
people are impacted
i had no idea now here i was opposing
a destructive and insane and oppressive
government policy and then the hill
comes in and says well yeah but the
policy will help some gay people
well okay then never mind i stand
corrected
if gay people will be helped
please take all of my private property
rights take away the gun rights too and
free speech
take away my very life if you're if it
will help
if that would be beneficial to some gay
people i submit to the desires of our
lgbt masters do what you will my lords
i'm sorry for having defied you
this anyway is the reaction that we're
expected to have i guess here's the
article it says about half of lgbt u.s
renters who are behind on their payments
fear eviction in the next two months
according to research released by the
university of california los angeles
williams institute
the williams institute compiled a brief
examining housing stability during the
coronavirus pandemic using data from the
u.s census bureau's pulse survey the
research found that 19 of lgbt
respondents said that they are behind on
rent of those 47 percent said that they
fear eviction the next two months
the findings from the survey come after
the supreme court last week blocked an
eviction freeze put in place by the by
administration to shield financially
vulnerable americans during the pandemic
well did anybody explain this to the
supreme court
did anyone present this powerful legal
argument that the eviction freeze is
good because some gay people might be
evicted without it
was this legal case laid out to the
justices it should be if it hasn't been
some more from the article says william
institute researchers also found that 41
percent of lgbt respondents rent their
homes compared to 25 percent of their
straight cisgender counterparts about 39
of lgbt people owned a house with a
mortgage or a loan compared to almost 48
percent of non-lgbt people in addition
more lgbt people of color 47 rent their
homes compared to 37 percent of white
lgbt respondents 51 percent of lgbt
people of color said that they feared
eviction the next two months compared to
38 of white lgbt people uh 47 of
non-lgbt people of color and 46 percent
of white non-lgbt people the williams
institute's brief concluded that a key
component of a person's housing
stability is whether they own or rent
lgbt people and specifically those of
color are more likely to be impacted by
the kova 19 pandemic
a study released by the williams
institute in february
found that lgbt people of color were two
times more likely to contract cover 19
compared to their straight white
counterparts
well geez
now i'm against covid ii
on second thought i mean now that you've
told me that i'm i'm opposed to covet
i had no idea that my race and sexual
orientation afforded me immunity from
the virus
and now frankly i feel the ethical
responsibility to go out and get
infected on purpose
and to infect many other straight white
people
as well just to kind of even out the
score a little bit
since we're keeping score apparently
now if it seems like i'm just keeping
sarcastic scorn here and offering
nothing else you're exactly right
because this kind of intersectional
madness
that's what it deserves
just our scorn and ridicule and sarcasm
there is no way to engage with it
honestly or coherent coherently anyway
because it's not put forward honestly or
coherently
just starting with the first sentence it
says about half of lgbt people behind on
their rent fear eviction well yeah and
that's not the same thing as saying that
half of lgbt people period fear eviction
it's to say that half of the people who
are behind on their rent fear it
but shouldn't everyone who hasn't paid
their rent for your eviction
i mean should should the number be like
100
this is like saying that that half of
lgbt people lgbt people who are
currently speeding down the road without
a seat belt fear a fatal car accident
well yeah and that but that's good
it's not good that they're speeding
down the road uh you know recklessly
but it's at least good that they're
aware
of the consequences and they're mildly
concerned about it
so i have more questions about the other
half really
also you could easily flip this around
and you could phrase it the other way
and you could say nearly 100
of lgbt people who pay their rent
do not fear eviction
so that's awesome looks like everything
is fine after all
but but here i am doing exactly what i
said i wouldn't do and we shouldn't do
engaging with the argument
because there's nothing really to engage
with here
the sexual orientation of people who
haven't paid their rent is of absolutely
no consequence or relevance at all
there's no reason to even talk about it
the wrongness or rightness of the
eviction moratorium would not change one
iota
if 100 of all lgbt people would be
evicted without it
why should it
i mean do the moral or legal facts
change depending on what identity group
the uh the affected people belong to
well yes that's exactly what the people
who do this kind of research and blast
it out in their headlines want us to
think the point for them is really
twofold
one
we're supposed to abandon our position
at the behest of a protected class of
people
you know
they say oh you're you're uh
you want to get rid of the eviction
moratorium well did you know
that if we do that there might be some
lgbt people who are evicted and we're
supposed to say well never mind
and two the main thing here is that this
now enables the eviction moratorium
advocates to claim
that abolishing the eviction moratorium
is homophobic
and an anti-gay conspiracy
that's the setup
that's actually what they're doing here
so look for that talking point to be
rolled out shortly if it hasn't been
already
like clockwork entirely predictable but
no less insidious not to mention
ridiculous and annoying and insane and
for that reason the hill today
is of course
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire
2021.
today on the ben shapiro show president
biden shows the world that his empathy
is an act with a blame-shifting nasty
vindictive bloviating speech championing
his afghanistan withdrawal and the
fallout will be toxic that's today on
the bench spiro show give it a listen